[Music]
here in this video we will showcase 15
biggest kaijus from the Kaiju Universe
the awesome multiplayer fight to the
death game with gigantic monsters woo
along with well-known Titans too
Godzilla Kaiju and other film
adaptations they also have unique takes
on the different monsters here so let's
take a look at the biggest at number 15
we have titanis Behemoth this is a Titan
from the monsterverse taken from the
monsterverse and it measures 107.9 M or
354 ft Tan's Behemoth is a hulking
Mammoth slot kaju that is also primarily
a melee fighter in the game number 14
Frozen Behemoth so this is a unique and
kind of original Kaiju in this game as
in there is no Frozen Behemoth from the
moster us movies or Comics anyway he
measures the same in height as the
previous is Behemoth but has a white
body with ice spikes on his back number
13 the cleric Muto this is another
unique semi original kaju from the game
the cleric Muto is seen as a mix between
a female Muto and a wendigo from
American folklore both with a burning
Aura it is 110 M or 360 ft tall number
12 Shin Godzilla also known as kakurasan
here in the game this is the fourth form
of shin Godzilla as seen in the movie it
has all the elements of this iteration
from the movie including the thermal
breath the pink laser Atomic breath and
a dorsal beans for area of effect
attacks number 11 thermonuclear Godzilla
this is a Game Pass exclusive Kaiju from
the 2019 film king of the monsters he is
a formidable close squads fighter in the
game his thermonuclear Atomic pulse is
one of the most devastating attacks in
the game with a wide reach and AA of
effect number 10 Godzilla
2021 gbk's entry is a high tier Kaiju
known for his impressive power and speed
with a rapid Atomic breath that inflicts
substantial damage without a charge up
coupled with put melee attacks he is
easily one of the most powerful kaijus
in this game number nine moera mogera
originating from the 1957 film The
Mysterion is a Mecca with the design
although adapted from the 1994 film
Godzilla versus Space Godzilla it is a
very powerful Mecha Kaiju in this game
it measures 120 M of 393 7 ft tall
number eight destoya this Kaiju is one
of if not definitely the most strongest
Kaiju in the game that is if you don't
count the developers like the Argo and
Dau taken from the Hy movie Godzilla
versus destoy of 1995 he is the
Incarnation of the oxygen Destroyer
weapon that killed the original God
jira number seven frostbite Godzilla so
this original Godzilla Kaiju of this
game is what I am presuming might
actually be the inspiration for the new
moov movie you know gxk the new Empire
the ancient Titan shimu who was inspired
from this one so that's what I'm
thinking anyway frostbite Godzilla has a
wide range of frost attacks and it is
the first to inflict status effects and
knockback attacks number six the muto
Prime the muto Prime introduced in the
2019 graphic novel Godzilla Aftershock
is a formidable late game Kaiju here
engaging it in close range attacks is
risky due to its powerful and damaging
attacks which has quite a powerful AA of
affect damage making it difficult to
evade it also stands at 120 m in
height number five biolante biolante
also is 120 M tall and it is a hybrid of
a genetically modified rose and a Kaiju
taken from the 1989 film Godzilla versus
bolante notably the kaju part is
actually Godzilla itself making it a
part of the gjira lineage number four
volcanic bolante measuring the same size
as B lante and the others but with new
lava and fiery Powers this Kaiju is a
redesigned and a modified volcanic
version of the hybrid Kaiju it is set in
its premise that volcanic biolante
absorb the energy from a volcano and
unleashes it upon everything around him
number three meca Godzilla
2021 this Mecca Titan serves as the main
enemy in the film Godzilla versus K it
is the biggest of the three Mecha
Godzillas in this game it has powerful
melee attacks which includes a punch and
a kick which releases blue energy and
also the proton scream it is 122 M or
400 ft tall number two hes King gidora
taken from the 1991 too film Godzilla
versus King gdor the Hasty incarnation
of Gora here is a large creature
standing 150 M or 492 ft tall with
imposing Wings when used strategically
it proves capable of defeating multiple
powerful kiju at the same time in this
game and number one Monster Zero monster
Zer is taken from the Godzilla movie
king of the monsters notably this is the
first appearance of Garo in an American
Film it is one of the most complex and
advanced kaju in the Kaiju Universe game
and despite it being a flying kaju it is
also one of the biggest here with a
height of 158 M of 518 ft tall now those
are the 15 biggest Kaiju from the Kaiju
Universe game if you like this video
then watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other monster
verse and monster content like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next video take
care fam